- L'année qui se termine aurait
s'emballe et des éléments qui
se déchaînent comme jsss
à la grandeur du Canada.
En tête de la liste
d'Environnement Canada : l
canadien à la fin du mois de
juin et provoqué le décès
prématuré de plus de
- Le 29 juin, à Lytton,
il a fait presque 50 degrés,
un record naalalal absolu.
- Nous sommes ici en train de
manger de la glace pour le petit
- Toujours dans l'Ouest, mais
en novembre, des trombes d'eau
se déversent sur la région
en l'espace de deux jours
dans certains secteurs.
délogées, les fermes qui
disparaissent, le bétail
qu'on récupèésésésésésésésésésé.
- Le pays entier est éararararae
période de sécheresse, causant
l'un des plus faibles rendements
agricoles annuels jamais
- On oususususussi des sommets
inégalés en terme de feux
de forêts.
incendies dévastateurs qui ont
détruit lelelelelent d'une fois
et demi la territoire de
l'Ile-du-Prince-Édouardêêêêêêêê.
- On tient nos doigts croisés
ait de la pluie, assez de pluie.
- Il y a un toît qui est parti!
des tornades plus fréquentes,
qui frappent en série,
quatre qui s'abattent sur le sud
du Québec le 21 juin dernier.aru
voisin, la toîture était partie,
je regarde ma "shed", elle était
toute éventrée.
- Le plus troublant, pensent les
spécialistes, c'est qu'en raison
des changements climatiques,
pourrait devenir la règle.
SIMON LEGAULT, météorologue,
Environnement et Changement
climatique Canada
terme, oui, il faut se préparer
à vivre cntntntntntnts-là, il
faut s'adpater, il faut aussi
faire des choix, quand on parles
façons de les combattre, c'est
des choix qui doivent être faits
et le plus tôt sera vraiment
- Environnement Canada estime
que l'année clim1 1 1 1 1 1 est
probablement la plus coûteuse
de notre histoire sur les plans
environnementaux.
Ici Normand Grondin